c'est avec émotion que nous avons appris
cet après-midi la mort soudaine du
joueur de rugby christophe dominici à
l'âge de 48 ans un joueur reconnu en
france qui a commencé à faire parler de
lui dès 1993 lorsqu'il intègre le rc
toulon très vite son jeu singulier son
talent le mène au plus haut niveau celui
du stade français c'est avec cette
équipe mythique qu'à partir de 1997 il
enchaîne ses plus belles années au poste
d'ailier il remporte deux tournois des
six nations et décroche 5 titres de
champion de france
il avait un son compteur 67 sélections
dans le quinze de france en 2008 à
l'issue d'une carrière sportive bien
remplie christophe dominici décide de
prendre une retraite bien méritée une
retraite sportive mais pas médiatique
puisque en 2012 il participe à
l'émission de tf1 danse avec les stars
il enchaîne ensuite quelques essais en
tant que comédien puis devient
consultant pour france télévisions
l'équipe 21 ou encore rtl
pour l'heure les circonstances de sa
disparition restent encore incertaines
[Musique]
christophe dominici qui nous a quittés
il a été retrouvé mort donc cet après
midi au parc de saint cloud et on a mon
ami celui que j'aime énormément aussi
c'est vincent moscato qui étaient avec
nous par téléphone
vincent merci d'être avec nous ce soir
je sais que tu es extrêmement ému merci
à vincent d'être là - vincent tu sûreté
évidemment extrêmement abattu par la
mort de christophe qui a été soudaine et
c'est vrai que si c'est un immense
joueur c'est un gars qu'on adore a eu la
chance de rencontrer une fois ces voix
là c'est ainsi c'est un c'est un mythe
bien sûr c'est un mythe le ciel avec hec
tous leurs différends
sa rancune parfois parfois t'es pas
courage et au départ et toute la face
avant par des mecs parlent d'un parité
de ce genre de deux joueurs que tout
donne des forces ça peut être un joueur
hors normes au niveau du jeu avec un
gabarit comme tout un peu moyen mais qu
avec dynamisme et un courage je me
rappelle il était capable en défens de
retourner n'importe qui il a rentré
souviendra d'eux de l'effet contre jonah
lomu qu'était montre que des bulldozers
qui est un tract pourquoi lemay calé à
deux mains alors justement regarde les
pompiers ont là ce soir on voulait
mettre ce soir
c'était en demi finale de la coup du
monde 99 face aux all blacks c'est etc
mais c'est vrai que c'était engine la
danseuse exceptionnelle christophe 2000
déjà plus aux normes tous et le la
vitesse au reggae c'est une chose mais
faut être capable de daf déjà produit
fiscal des français et 81 kg il se jeter
dans les roues du camion n'en avoir
aucune peur avec intel troupeau de vie
d'homme qui arrive et est capable de se
jeter au milieu compliqué tout le monde
il était peu après c'était autre chose
c'est un camarade en perthois le canton
des fois on parle de l'argent de notre
sport et tout ça mais tous les sports
sont qu'un de solidifier que 30 des 32
bon et lui et lui était vraiment un
leader dans le dallas leader et tout le
monde l'écouté il était un beau un bon
mec un bon gamin vraiment alors selon la
fpc s'agirait d'un suicide
ça m'a encore plus peiné quand j'ai
quand j'ai appris ça parce que c'est
vrai que vraiment il respirait la joie
de vivre
christophe dominici et tu savais toi
vincent qui voilà qui avait des soucis
ou pas du tout eu la brique sommes nous
vraiment aujourd'hui des tons gris
non je suis déçu comme tout comme
czaplicki se suicider répandue que que
je suis tombé des nues à 48 ans mourir à
40 qui comme je suis j'ai eu au
téléphone il ya quinze jours trois
semaines 3 donc je suis tombé des nues
après c'était même un kit était un peu
aux trois hits et turbulente c'est la
turbulente et je savais que parfois ils
avaient des soucis dans sa tête mais
comme beaucoup de joueurs qu'on puisse
dire est qu'ils ont parfois des soucis
après c'est difficile de 2,2 me toujours
de penser au pire une bille n'y pense
jamais était toute une surprise peut te
dire il va pas très bien où est notre
choix parmi eux et jamais tu pense au
pire le pire attitude de n'imagine
jamais c'est un homme qui en pleine
forme et cas est qu'à la joie que les
cadets capacité à être un enthousiasme
d'asie à la boule c'est de la vie comme
s'il en pleuvait toi et donc donc tu te
s'attend pas si surpris alors après
qu'il ait des soucis on a tous des
soucis mais là j'ai l'impression qu'il y
avait des soucis mais y avait des gros
soucis l'impression d'une histoire hélas
on peut pas se mettre à faire pas son
genre moi je m'en rendais pas compte que
je m'en suis pas rendu compte
vincent je souhaite remercier d'avoir pu
nous parler ce soir chez une grosse
pensée bien sûr pour la famille de
christophe gouget ce jour pour l'honneur
et pour mon ami bien sûr bernard laporte
qui était le parrain de sa fille le
parrain de sa fille et qui est mon ami
bernard vous le savez qui a été
extrêmement touché n'a même pas pu
s'exprimer aujourd'hui bernard après
avoir appris là la disparition de de
clint haymon vincent je t'aime
fournitures et je sais que c'est dur on
est on est là on tue l'info je sais que
c'est dur pour toi et je remercie
d'avoir été là bon vin sans vraiment je
te fais des membres à bisous et je
t'aime fort mon vincent dans merci merci
vincent moscato qui leur est avec nous
qu'est un amour de mecs aussi et c'est
vrai c'est vrai que ces gars là où on
les aime
cdt dégâts voilà c'était des exemples et
voilà dans le sport c'est vrai que voilà
christophe vincent il s'était très
soudée bernard laporte vous dire il est
très très très atteint très touché par
ses passes et christophe dominici qui
avait participé à la troisième saison de
dalt de danse avec les stars aux côtés
de candice pascal regarder
[Musique]
mais
ce
tous les
[Musique]
christophe dominici qui nous a quittés
immense joueur de rugby
c'était un des plus doués christophe
dominici et oui jean michel le suicide
ne fait pas de doute pour les enquêteurs
il ya un témoin qui l'a vu se jeter de
cet immeuble désaffecté du parc de saint
cloud en proche région parisienne c'est
juste à côté d'un juste à côté voilà et
d'après mes informations n'avaient pas
de l'être sur lui qui expliquait son
geste
voilà ce que j'ai réussi renseigner mais
pas de geste a peut-être qu'il a essayé
de n'être naître chez lui on espère pour
sa famille qu'il y aurait une pierre
quelqu'un qui part sans laisser
d'explication vraiment comme ça donc on
espère chez lui ils sont en train de
faire rezé d une enquête pour savoir
s'il essayait un mot d'explication
auprès de sa famille sa famille était
convoqué sa femme a été convoquée s'il
devra d'apprendre ça comme tu es là
c'est vrai que mais ils étaient torturés
il était torturé il a écrit un livre
isabelle bleus dans l'amour où il
raconte dedans justement depuis la mort
de sa soeur en 1986 il n'a pas réussi à
s'en remettre
il est allé dans la drogue l'alcool
c'est le rugby qui l'a mis dans le droit
chemin après il avait des hauts et des
bas aussi dans sa vie conjugale il a
essayé de racheter un club de rugby ça
avorté malheureusement et ça contribue
aussi un petit peu à sa chute donc je
dis pas que ceci explique cela
mais c'était quand même une âme torturée
mais toujours disponible pour ses fans
il était toujours là quand ils
l'attendaient à la sortie des matchs
pour signer toujours toujours disponible
oui guillaume moi je n'ai rencontré
plusieurs fois sur la troisième saison
de danse avec les stars et c'était un
des seuls qui se prenait pas du tout
pour une star il était très humble il
parlait tout le temps aux équipes
techniques qui s'intéressait aux autres
ce qui est très rare chez ses maîtres de
dire ça mais chez des personnalités et
j'ai eu candice pascal cet après midi
qui était sa danseuse qui était
bouleversée d'apprendre cette chine rien
on a on a 100 témoignages en interaction
10 passes calme c'est pascal qui était
sa danseuse fac et danse avec lui dans
ces questions
je suis tellement tout choc l'aide
christophe c'était vraiment le mec
mais qui perd solaire toujours à faire
des blagues
il avait vraiment l'esprit du bon vivant
sportif en fait ouvert les portes de sa
famille comme c'est sa femme c'est
quelqu'un qui était vraiment riche alors
tu crois que le côté bon vivant un
épicurien le rugby merci à candice
pascal d'avoir réagi et ya même eu un
hommage à l'assemblée nationale cet
après midi les députés ont tenu à lui
rendre hommage aux dames d'abord et
malheureusement parce que je viens de
l'apprendre je voudrais faire par
l'assemblée de mon émotion en apprenant
la mort la mort de légende du quinze de
france de six jeunes christophe dominici
n'allait pas 50
nous lui rendrons sûrement de grands
dommages mais c'est évidemment très
grande émotion tout l'apprenons demain
on aura peut-être bernard laporte avec
nous je sais pas encore on va pas le
port c'est bernard voilà peut-être qu'il
viendra nous dire un petit mot puisqu'il
était très très proche de christophe
dominici